[Captions by Y Translator]
Today, we're going to see if we can
use focused sunlight to fire a bullet.
[Music]
This is a bullet.
A 22 caliber bullet,
and this is our solar scorcher,
and today, we are going to see
if we can use the solar scorcher
to focus sunlight to fire the bullet.
The idea here is pretty simple.
We have a small metal plate
that we'll rest the bullet on,
and focus the sunlight
by tipping our solar scorcher.
We want to know if the sunlight will
be enough to get the bullet to fire.
This plate doesn't
really hold the bullet much.
It just keeps it from rolling, so that it
will end up exactly where we want to go.
This cord is attached to the top of our
solar scorcher, and by pulling on it,
we can tip the solar scorcher until it's
focused right where we want it.
The cord is going to be pulled
from about 50 feet away,
inside the cover of a concrete dome,
which is perpendicular to the path
of where the bullet is aimed.
Even if the bullet managed to
shoot with the force of a gun
in our direction,
we'll be behind a concrete
wall about a foot thick.
We also have a couple
of pieces of foam core,
and we're just going to set those
up behind and in front of our bullet
to see if it happens to shoot straight
enough to pass right through.
Now, because this plate isn't
holding the shell in place,
it is pretty likely that the shell
and bullet will shoot off in opposite
directions with approximately
equal power.
Of course, all of that's assuming
that the sunlight is enough to
set it off in the first place,
and I think it's time we do a test.
First, we're going to remove the bullet
and put a small stick in its place.
We'll test pulling the solar scorcher with a
rope, seeing if we can angle it just right
so that it starts burning that stick.
That's going to be how we know
if we have enough heat on it
to try and light off the bullet.
It certainly lights
that stick up pretty well.
Now, let's try it with the bullet.
[Music]
That's a fire.
I don't know where the pieces
went, but, here's the bullet part.
I don't know what that hit.
Or like if it just popped apart.
We're gonna have to watch the footage,
you know, even if it does that 50 times,
I'm not going to stand out here next to it,
because you never know,
that one time might be bad.
Oh, but there's an impact mark.
Is that from the shell?
Maybe the bullet hit that and bounced?
Interesting.
There's a slight impact mark.
Doesn't even go through to the other
side, but something hit it.
Interesting.
The shell...
This board has nothing except, well,
it does have a couple of tiny spots,
but those might have already been there.
I guess I didn't pay
enough attention to that.
Let's check the footage, and see
if we can figure out what happened.
No way to tell where it went.
To me, it looked like both
pieces like that way, but...
Wait, can we see the bullet
land back on here?
Let's try this again.
[Music]
Kinda surprised it
takes as long as it does.
This solar scorcher can actually
melt a bullet shell, so it's possible
I don't have it focused quite right.
Getting the height is really tricky.
[Music]
There it goes.
The last time, we had an impact.
This time, we caught the bullet.
Oh, that's great.
So not a lot of force on that bullet,
if it can't even shoot its way through
a single piece of foam core.
It dented the back, but it
didn't make it all the way through.
Oh, there you go magicians.
That's how you do a bullet catch.
You just have the bullet not be in a gun,
set it off with the power of sunlight,
and catch it in a piece of foam core.
Nothing could be easier.
It did go pretty straight.
That was almost
exactly where it was aimed.
Of course, it also hit the foam core
sideways, so it was tumbling a bit.
Lack of rifling will do
that, and I really just don't
know what happened to the shell.
Didn't leave a mark, so it didn't
shoot off straight backwards,
unless it ran right into the wood.
Oh, maybe it did.
There's a little chip
in the wood right here.
That's pretty in line with it.
Oh, that is probably it.
And that didn't just shoot
the bullet that, that is destroyed.
Wow.
So not being containing
a gun, that just exploded.
That's cool.
I'm going to move the foam core to
the other side of the wooden leg support.
[Music]
That was quicker.
Oh, we got a good focal point on it.
Okay, we definitely caught
the shell with the board this time.
In fact, I believe it shot right through.
That's the most powerful impact
we've had with a piece of foam core so far.
The bullet didn't make it through.
This last shot...
I don't see any indication
of where the bullet hit.
I think we just lost it.
Maybe it went off sideways.
I'm not sure, but the shell...
It looks like it launched
right through, and so I'm not
sure where it would have ended up.
Probably didn't get too far given how
much power we've seen that these things
don't have before,
but, it exploded nicely.
Setting off bullets with the power
of sunlight, definitely possible.
But now, I do want to take it one step
further, and rather than just setting
the bullet on top of this metal tray,
I'm actually going to try
and grip the shell in the vise itself,
and see if we can get it to
shoot with the force of a bullet.
[Music]
We've got a couple pieces
of veg tanned leather right here,
and we're just using those to help
grip the bullet shell more evenly,
so it's not just biting into the rim.
[Music]
You can see the leather smoking.
Random Fact: The average bullet
travels at 2,500 feet per second,
which is roughly twice
as fast as the speed of sound.
[Music]
Yeah.
Alright, we got the bullet to fire.
The leather dropped out,
and the shell is not here.
I was hoping it would end up with just
a shell being held in the vise.
Maybe we try squeezing a little bit harder.
As for the bullet, let's see.
Did we hit our...
I don't see any indication
of a bullet mark on our board here.
So, I'm gonna assume we missed.
Oh, there's one little chip.
That might be from a bullet,
that might have just been a scratch.
I'm not sure.
[Music]
It's also possible the shell is
exploding. When the shell explodes,
doesn't really matter how well it's being
held, 'cause there's not much shell left.
[Music]
Bam!
Fires quick when it's properly focused.
Mmm.
It smells like burning leather, delightful.
Still no indication of a bullet impact,
and once again, the leather
was blown clear, and we have no shell.
Let's try again, and squeeze
it down even tighter.
[Music]
Bam!
Alright, even with all that,
we still lost our shell...
[Music]
And...
I'm not seeing much
in the way of an impact spot.
[Music]
Like not so much as a dent really.
Sunlight and bullets.
Can you use concentrated
sunlight to fire off a bullet?
Turns out, yes, you can.
It fires just sitting in a tray,
it fires held in the vise.
We did not get any results that indicate
that you can get a bullet to go
where you want it by using sunlight.
We could probably build a nice
little complicated mechanism that holds
the shell on almost all sides,
but just lets in enough sunlight to
set it off, and maybe then we could
get it to shoot a nice straight line.
But overall, I would say this is
a terribly impractical
way to shoot bullets.
The sun moves, or more accurately,
we move in reference to the Sun,
and that makes it so you have to realign your
solar scorcher, your magnifying lens.
Like every couple of minutes,
we were just having to move and adjust,
and move the solar scorcher,
move the vise, move the bullets
back and forth.
So it can work.
I don't recommend it.
In fact, this is not really
a super safe activity,
so there's no reason to do this anyway.
But we just wanted to know
if it was possible, and it is.
The solar scorcher does get hot
enough to ignite the gunpowder
within the shell, and fire off a bullet.
Although, like we saw,
not with much force.
It almost managed to pierce
a piece of foam core,
which pretty sure most
people could punch through.
So it does fire, just not with as much
power as you might be interested in.
Guys, thanks for watching,
but the fun doesn't end here.
That box up at the top
will transport you
directly to our last video,
and you should check that one out.
The other box will show you what YouTube
think you should be watching next,
and if you haven't joined the club yet,
hit this bomb to become a subscriber,
and that way, you
never miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.